What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience?
Well,
that's one thing that we did learn from talking to Jack Dorsey,
the CEO of Twitter,
like it's impossible to manage.
There's too many.
Yeah.
Hosts.
They're going up right now by the thousands.
Like if you could see everyone,
everyone in America posting on Twitter right now,
I'd be like,
oh,
[inaudible].
I mean,
imagine all happening.
Oh,
no.
Explosion.
Oh my God.
Ones and Zeros just fussed and all over the place and text.
Just chat.
Who Do you think,
like if you were to grab somebody's phone,
the most popular person that gets tweeted the most just emotion.
Just looked at it.
How fast would that go?
You know what I mean?
Like just that,
that one account.
Oh,
be insane.
I mean,
years probably going to sleep some people or do you just pull stuff out of the
people?
Yeah.
I follow a lot of other people.
I just followed whenever,
whenever things,
someone's interesting.
So he's got cool pictures of follow that guy.
Yeah.
I just like first,
yeah.
Let me see.
Let me go back to see what else.
This person's not wacky.
It's really funny.
As people get mad at you for certain people,
you follow people that you guys stop following our Kelly now don't tell them
what to do.
Right.
That's first of all.
First of all,
don't tell him what to do.
Second of all,
what am I doing?
Am I boosting up his profile?
He's fucking art Kellogg.
Okay.
It doesn't matter if I follow them.
If I don't,
I want to know how crazy he is.
That's right,
dude.
Did you see Tyron,
Tyron Woodley,
UFC,
a top welterweight former champion had a thing on his Instagram page of him
watching our Kelly getting interviewed and where,
who's who was?
Who is denying that he knows how to hog tie people.
It's laughing at him.
Play this,
play this.
He's all and this interview.
Yeah.
It's just crazy.
Shit.
Ain't funny,
but dog.
Oh,
Tyler.
I sent me
paper called Tyler Hoag.
That's great.
He's not using a confident today.
He's like,
ha ha,
Ho Ho.
Hey,
I follow are Kelly for the same reason?
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
that I'd love real talk if you haven't watched that video.
Real talk.
We played it on the podcast multiple times.
The real target is one of the greatest unintentional comedies that's ever been
real talk.
Real talk I and say it.
Oh my God,
what is it?
It's an art Kelly Song.
Okay.
Where he's in an argument with his girlfriend on the phone while he was in the
car fare,
was girlfriend on the phone.
He's like getting his hair done and shit.
He's smoking stoke,
he's drinking.
It's got like different outfits on and he's still in the conversation and
there's one part where he goes,
bitch,
I wish you would my mother clothes Lou real talk bitch.
I wish you would burn my motherfucking clothes real time.
I serious about that.
Listen,
I absolutely feel for any person that he's victimized,
absolutely do.
Yeah,
but you cannot deny that that that it is hilarious.
That shit is fun.
There is.
Hold on.
I just play that
fucking
trifling.
Ass
trifling is the best.
It is best African-american's saying of all prideful Triflin Triflin and it's
one that why people cannot use.
It's too,
I pronounced it too good.
They on that word.
Hey on that word.
As much as they own the n word.
Right.
Top trifle Ling,
you can't be traveling.
He can announced the g and trifling.
Yeah,
you can.
Yeah.
That's why white people are not allowed to use it.
They would ruin it.
Exactly.
He's out there trifling.
He's out there trifling shit.
He's just a bullshit trifling ass trifling.
Well,
here's the thing.
I bet gay guys use trifling.
I bet gay guys,
I'll pull it out out with him over there,
but it's trifling ass.
I know.
It sounds like a rifle that you travel with until trifle it.
Yeah,
like a triathlon is a travel rifle to think at a banning those.
They're good for long range.
Don't bring a trifle with many people.
Do you think had to look it up before Webster had to like answer this question.
What does a trifling heifer
did?
Try for laugh,
lacking insignificance or solid worth such as a frivolous,
trifling,
be trivial.
A trifling gift.
See,
chiefly dialectical,
my God,
lazy shiftless in a triathlon fellow trifling fellow trifling fellow is eight.
That's the most English thing that ever say.
It got very wide at the fellow.
He's a trifling fed up.
Don't bring y'all off.
Shall they hear without Kathleen?
Hello?
Yeah,
that's a word,
bro.
That's a,
that's a legit word.
Trifling Shit.
That was going to say something else.
I totally forgot.
What did we talk about right before teach them our Kelly Kelly.
Yeah.
I like that point.
He did an album where it was a lot of just talking.
Oh,
trapped in the closet.
Yeah.
There was a whole series of videos.
I think Aziz had a whole thing on that.
I think we did like Aziz Ansari did a bit on it,
I believe so.
I know he had a bit,
yeah,
about r Kelly.
It might've been about trapped in the closet.
Yeah.
Trapped in the closet is great,
but it can't fuck with real talk.
Real talk.
Real talk to the jam.
Yeah.